it's one of the great things about
accelerators
is
they can take more chances and founders
who are taking risk doing really risky
things
are like you know what i'm giving up
yeah six percent seven percent for a
hundred or 150 k but my idea is crazy
nobody wants to fund it
screw it if i if i get some validation
here if i can build some consensus
around this and learn
you know it could be um
just the type of transformative thing
that actually gets people to embrace it
i've had so many companies come to our
accelerator as well that were unfundable
before we had them in the accelerator
and then suddenly they get through the
accelerator they learn how to pitch the
product they hear all the objections
um maybe the product you know
uh gets refined a little bit and then
all of a sudden you just need one
investor right i mean you only need one
and then you're off to the races what
product broke out first there must have
been a product
that just sold out captured the press's
imagination and just went crazy for you
what was it
well you know i don't know that there's
one but i think you know part of our
magic is the curation of the site as you
kind of touched on a little bit earlier
and you know for the first call at four
or five years everything was kind of
hand-picked and literally went through
my belly before it got on the side
and uh it was
and that's why i put on 25 pounds i'm
working on getting it off but um so it's
it's
it's iconic foods from around the
country it's the most loved foods
it's uh not every food from every maker
it's the most cherished and signature
items
and um it's foods that travel well and
taste delicious so i think i think we
captured people's imagination when you
know somebody in san francisco could get
new york bagels when they've been
complaining about how the bagels are you
know for decades
uh the same thing you know new york
pizza or um you know you name the
regional dish
um there's these locally legendary shops
that just do it better
from the places that originated them
places that perfected them um and so i
think you know everything from new york
bagels and new york deli
uh to every kind of barbecue you know
barbecue is like the regional american
food
and we have these great barbecue makers
from from the four capitals of yeah
somebody sent me a brisket um you know
caroline i'm not saying
this is brisket uh for my birthday last
year from gold belly i can't remember
which one it was from but it was
dynamite and i smoked my own brisket and
i was super impressed i mean joe's pizza
was
one of the canonical examples of like
people wanting to ship stuff did you
ever get them on the platform back in
the day
i know people
yeah we worked with them
yeah we worked with them for years um
[Music]
and uh de fara is another uh like great
new york institution that that we ship
um now what happens when people figure
out how to do this you teach them how to
do it you prove there's a market do they
then just leave and do it themselves are
are people encroaching on the businesses
like ubereats or postmates starting to
try to get in on this amazon or
um
are you still
like the first option for people
yeah i think you know our um the volume
of our sales is pretty substantial right
now for food makers
um
you know we have many many partners that
do millions of sales millions of dollars
a year uh
millions of dollars what's the top
number like you know
in the name of the
thing like who made the most last year
who's making the most this year like
most in a month 10 million a year five
million years three million a year
obviously we can't just don't
but it's in in the uh
yeah it's it's closer to the ten million
dollars worth of products
one vendor on there that's right and
what do you guy what's your take you
guys take 25 or something or is it
negotiated or is it a flat rate what is
it how does that work
yeah it's negotiated so
so so jason one of the things you have
to realize is so we've created this
market you know 98 of our partners have
never shipped anything before
we worked with them on doing it and so
there's this whole like innovation stack
that that comes with that and it's
everything from
managing the shipping and logistics
manage the managing the technology and
the dashboards obviously bringing in the
customers but even curating
the packages of what the products are
we're not shipping you one cheesesteak
out to san francisco
everything is kind of bundles more group
kind of packages
and so um
it's not apples to apples generally with
the things that that you might see on a
local delivery site and we actually let
our partners set the price
we figure out the logistics cost and of
course you know we have a margin um on
every order but there's no like fixed
rate card and we work on a case-by-case
basis depending on each product uh it's
time and transit what the products are
what's the most popular uh what are the
three most popular items this year you
know and during pandemic what broke out
so it's
every month there's different things
that are hot right like in the summer
time it might be something different
that's totally different during gift
season
comfort foods
right
as a as a mission our company is our our
mission as a company is to bring people
comfort through food
whatever they dream of wherever they are
and i think food is very personal so
like jason's comfort food might be
totally different than joe's comfort
food and so for some people it's pizza
for some people it's barbecue for some
people it's a decadent cake or ice cream
sandwiches and so it really is on a
case-by-case basis but i'll say one of
the really exciting categories that's
grown the fastest for us
is high-end chefs yes meal kits yes so
restaurant we're talking about staffs
that you would have thought would have
never thought about shipping in the past
we work with them at a really high level
to create these packages and create
these like unbelievable chef meal kit
packages
what would you do with an extra 15 hours
every week for a lot of leaders there's
a moment where you realize that you are
in your own way delegating to someone
can be intimidating especially if you
don't know how to do it right and that's
exactly where belay comes in belay wants
to help business leaders by
revolutionizing productivity with their
virtual assistant services imagine how
your leadership could transform if you
didn't have to worry about reading every
email and scheduling every call yourself
and you had more time energy and focus
to work on things that can 10x your
business working with smbs is belay's
specialty but they also serve as c-suite
executives for maui gym
chick-fil-a and more you'll get a free
copy of rise up and lead well how
leveraging an assistant will change your
life and maximize your time it's written
by belay's ceo trisha shortino so here's
your call to action get back to focusing
on what matters growing your business
and leave the rest to belay just text
twist
55123 for your free copy of rise up and
lead well today just text twist
255 123 for your free copy of rise up
and lead well